so let's talk about uh biden and trump
then we'll expand upon this
you're you're super excited for biden uh
yes
oh yeah why um for every so
one i think that we will finally
hopefully have some
cohesive idea of how we're supposed to
deal with the coronavirus as a country
from somebody that is not insane when it
comes to talking about
virus-related stuff so no weird stuff
about bleach or uv lights
no pushing weird medications like
hydroxychloroquine that he didn't take
when he was sick
no he was reported that he took it uh no
he said he took it as a problem oh
right before he got sick when he
actually got sick he got the good stuff
he didn't get that
weird stuff that he was selling all the
suckers on tv that's worship and support
him
uh well but hydroxyl hydroxychloroquine
has been used for decades
it is considered not for covet 19. for
sure for sure so
there were preliminary studies this is
the craziest thing about the news cycle
and how they deal with trump
it was actually tech crunch and several
european outlets that reported
a promising study showing
hydroxychloroquine azithromycin
you know com with zinc in combination
with showing uh that the severity was
reducing
they actually replicated this in other
studies trump comes out and just starts
repeating it and then also the media
flipped on it
so we've installed we even saw lefties
write about this saying it is the
weirdest thing the moment trump says
something about a news report
the media changes the narrative and it's
a bad thing because well the problem is
it's not trump's job to be saying these
things
if a random tech crunch article wants to
come out and say hey there was some
retrospective analysis done
on hydroxychloroquine and antibiotics
like acetomycin no no it was literally a
study on covet
and they found the severity was
dramatically all of the prospective
studies done
on hydroxychloroquine have showed that
it is nothing it does not help with the
serrated disease there have been some
retrospectives that when compared
against different standards of care like
maybe
but the reason why it became popular
initially was because that scientists in
um france the doctor uh
raoul came out with his like n equals 12
study that i think he dropped one person
from that died and after like one
weekend he was like hey we published the
results
and then like that was it there were
there was a ton of past research that
said for coronavirus
and and for like czars covet one
heterosexual chloroquine was effective
in reducing severity
sure this probably led the scientists to
say let's try it out which is fine stars
covered two
good there were promising results early
on but as soon as trump said it the
media went nuts
that's the crazy thing trump's because
trump no he's like it's not his job
so here's part of the problem when trump
comes out and says it when trump comes
out and says something that hasn't been
thoroughly vetted by the medical
community isn't recommended by somebody
who would be more in line to recommend
that like say somebody like fauci
right when trump comes out and says it
it changes the worldwide discourse
when it comes to these drugs so there
was a really good article published in
nature about some research scientists
that complained
about how hard it was when they were
trying to run trials on other drugs so
dexamethasone and um rendezvous or other
drugs nobody
wants to be in the loser trials
everybody wants to be in the hydroxyl
chloride that's what trump was talking
about
what nobody wants to risk being in the
dummy trial for some loser drug when
trump is on tv talk about how he's
taking hydroxyl chlorine every day
like it's not his job to do that he's
absolutely responsible for him
on tv talking about that i disagree i
mean he's going to talk about what he
says in the news
i'm not going to blame him is he like a
muppet he sees something and he says
something this is like the most powerful
man in the world i think that we can be
a little bit everybody
trump is not everybody trump is the
president of the united states
and and he did he gave a speech where he
said we're doing a great job
we're seeing some promising studies out
of france there's a hydroxychloroquine
that they're talking about
should he not tell people that we're
making developments and there's some
promising
you know medications the problem is that
even if i was to grant you that it
stands in stark contrast to the reasons
why he gave for
never talking about the coronavirus
initially right like he's saying that
like oh well he keeps all this stuff
secret because i don't want to start a
panel
but now he's out here talking about all
these potential miracle drugs and
everything like
i i just i think that he's very
irresponsible for him like i even get
nervous talking about like certain
medications on my stream because i don't
want people to run out take and i know i
have that power and i'm not the
president of the united states right i
always just say
ask your doctor doctor knows best for
you which is great and if trump said
that you're like hey there are drugs out
there that might be trying to talk to a
doctor but that's not what he was saying
he was talking about oh we got
hydroxychlorogen this great new miracle
drug and i think it's going to be the
next
do you remember who are you today
remember what the white house said on
school closures
the science is on our side and anderson
cooper i think that's something
effective he just
doesn't care about your children at all
um i think jennifer rubin said he wants
your kids to die or something like that
this was actually what kelly mcinerney
brought up in a press reference mind you
that's one
so i remember that narrative when trump
uh and
the white house came out and said
schools should stay open
well now we're finding out that even
fauci is saying yep but so much later
that we've caused irreparable damage
to many people's lives and families and
there's been suicides
when trump was actually right the whole
time two was that irresponsible when
they said that that people can say
different people can say the same thing
for very different reasons
like it's very obvious that trump is
pushing to open schools because he's
desperate to get back to some level of
normalcy for the election because
whether you agree or disagree with trump
this election to a large extent was
probably a referendum on how he dealt
with the coronavirus
and getting people back in schools and
getting people working because a lot of
people don't know this
um schools are can be two very important
things for families
one it's how your kid can eat sometimes
depending on how poor you are and two
um it lets mom and dad go and work they
care because yeah
because daycare is unbelievably
expensive oh my goodness so public
schools allows
yeah the economy to keep moving yeah but
the problem is is that when you're
pushing for things on only a political
basis and it doesn't seem like you're
laying out like good comprehensive plans
for like um so for instance like fauci
and um i think he was even on the white
house talk of site
have like these plans for like slowly
reopening based on the number of
reported cases daily averages moving
blah blah blah
like if that was the type of thing that
was being said then i could have been
more empathetic
okay cool it seems like trump just wants
to reopen things in a responsible way
but instead of just like we got to open
all the schools you got to get them back
we got to get back to normal it was like
probably not like the most
science-driven answer he's given i mean
it's an it's an opinion the people who
like trump are going to say trump cares
about me and he's fighting for my family
the people who don't are going to say he
only cares about
why didn't trump pressure mcconnell to
release any stimulus if he cares about
our family so much
maybe he doesn't think stimulus is the
right way to help families and he
thought that
it would be devastating to the economy
to just print money and the best way to
do it was to release the lockdowns which
is what
i thought it was devastating to the
economy to just cut taxes for like all
the wealthy businesses or
to authorize the ppp loans that was good
for the economy
like people think that the heroes of
their own story you know sure i
understand
it's strange that he thought that these
were such positive measures but he
couldn't pressure mcconnell to release
any kind of stimulus to the average
american person
i think he said that the stimulus will
be the vaccine and
we need to reopen because people should
be working so it's just
there's i don't think there's mustache
twirling villainy i think
i don't think it's much i think it's
just selfish and stupid but the problem
is we are months and months into this
and we got
no other stimulus he is our leader where
was it
how do you feel about fauci saying uh
early on that he was doing the best
possible that no one could do better
every time somebody contradicts trump
they get immediately fired
look at the um i think it was the cyber
security head of the dhs that came out
and said well this election was actually
pretty secure and trump
instantly fired him so it's not
surprising to me that fouch a man that's
been working in government for what like
30 or 40 years or something
that he came out he's like oh yeah i
think trump he's been defying him for
months
he has been defying it but that's
there's a very careful line you have to
skirt
if you've ever worked a corporate job
and you've got an idiot manager you know
like you don't go out and say like
why are you doing this it's stupid it's
more like maybe i kind of i think you're
doing a great i could [ __ ]
sure yeah well you don't want to get
fired it's more like you're doing an
amazing job i think we could do a little
bit better here right so
you think you think fauci lied to the
american people to save his own job
i think that fauci was saying things in
the most diplomatic manner possible
because he wanted to serve the american
people and i get immediately fired by
trump
said he would saying trump did the best
possible job and no one could do better
is a big difference from
we're trying as hard as we can i don't
know if he said no one could do better
i would be or better i'd be curious the
exact quote is but even so i don't think
that's very relevant to policy going
forward whether or not fauci says that
trump did a good or bad job i don't know
if it's fauci's job
in government to be second guessing the
president in his past
decisions it's a fauci's job to give us
the best leadership going forward and i
know that there have been times where
fauci and you just said it right has
been at ends with the president and him
like promoting certain drugs or him
talking about certain things whether the
chronovirus professor says well i
disagree here or whatever and even i'm
pretty sure there were a few months
where we didn't see fouchy anymore
because of his like
behind the scenes fighting with trump
but yeah i don't think they're just
saying well fouchy said trump is doing a
good job like wow you think
like trump the guy that fires literally
every single person in government that's
not immediately agreeing with him like
it doesn't surprise me that he was like
a little bit careful when he would
publicly address trump so on that note
the cyber security guy that trump just
fired would it not have been in his best
interest to say this was the most secure
election we've ever had that's literally
him saying i did a good job don't fire
me
um but it's that type of thing is it's
very hard
um so like there's like two schools of
thought in terms like how to change a
system
do you go full renegade and say this
sucks this is over
fire me i don't care or do you kind of
like suck it up
work from the inside you know like okay
well sure this sucks but like if as long
as i like keep my you know mouth shut i
can actually enact change on the inside
like um when the dhs guy came out and
said what he said i think that he
probably felt an obligation to the
american people to let them know the
government doesn't stand behind trump
and his like
election fraud claims so i feel like
that doesn't surprise you so
i'll read a little bit he said without
you said we've never had a threat like
this and the coordinated response has
been
there are a number of adjectives to
describe it impressive i think is one of
them
i mean we're talking about all hands on
deck is that i as one of many people on
the team
i'm not the only person since the
beginning that we've recognized what
this was
i have been devoting almost uh almost
full time on this almost all
almost full time i'm down at the white
house virtually every day with the task
force i'm connected by phone throughout
the day
and into the night and when i say night
i'm talking 12 1 2
in the morning not just one so i can't
imagine that under any circumstance that
anybody could be doing more i mean
obviously we're fighting a formidable
enemy
this virus this virus is a serious issue
here take a look at what's under china
and you know yeah yeah
he he goes into really long i don't want
to read the full uh
it's a really long paragraph sure it
just sounds like he's like as the as
who's kind of become the face of this
virus he's like champion like yeah we're
doing everything we can the government
which is kind of what i would expect him
to do is to be like a cheerleader for
the government i don't know i'm gonna
come out and like
these guys suck are coordinated federal
response but non-existent
trump is a horrible leader like i don't
think that would be his job and would
probably send a bad message to the
american people as well
if you know the criticism of trump is
that he
was downplaying this early on to avoid a
panic and that was a bad thing
then isn't there responsibility on
fouchy the problem with trump if you
want to say that you're down playing
something
to avoid panic that's fine but the
problem was is that while he was
downplaying it there weren't steps being
taken behind the scenes to prepare us
for what was coming
it seemed less like downplaying it to
avoid a panic and more pretending it
didn't exist and hope didn't come to
american shores
because there's a darren's been publicly
saying like okay guys listen i don't
think this is going to be a big deal
and then behind the scenes you're like
okay listen we need to get testing on
board we need to make sure that we have
some form of contact tracing we need to
like communicate with governors make
sure we
like there would be that but instead it
was just like well look we locked down
travel from china lol
and then in a month and a half we did
nothing oh well we look we locked down
travel from uh
um from europe lol and like that's it
like i i don't think that he was just
trying to avoid a panic because there
was nothing going on behind the scenes
in that gap of the china and european
travel ban to show that he was taking it
seriously it seemed he just didn't think
it was a real thing
let's talk about biden sure what do you
uh what do you like about biden
um so one thing was the top down um
hopefully some
sort of top-down level uh response we
get for related to the coronavirus
um that respects rules and everything i
know i don't know if we've talked about
it yet on air but the supreme court did
cite that
yeah religious students which is
probably fine i can understand that
really from the supreme court
um i would hope that churches would
individually say like okay well maybe
we'll you know suspend sessions but
i can understand that um but some
top-down coordinated response from
um the government really the coronavirus
um number two
and three are close going to be
intertwined is going to be like the
economy broadly and healthcare broadly
um i'm very interested to see what sort
of economic policies
we're going to see from biden especially
in regards to his strong support of
unions
and especially in regards to i don't
personally like the policy but pushing
for 15 an hour minimum wage i'm very
curious to see like where that ends up
bad news why do you say that so he wants
to combine that with a high corporate
tax yes
that's bad and he's also been as part of
the obama administration very much in
favor of free trade agreements
i love free trade agreements well so you
know what the combination of those three
things will get you
corporations facing high wage costs and
high taxes will just move their their
factories and their their
businesses well that's part of what you
have baked into any multilateral trade
agreement though is the idea that um
so um nobody talks about this on the
right or the left one of the nice things
about free trade agreements or
multilateral trade agreements is that
obviously what you just said can happen
okay you um if you're going to
make it so that i can export my supply
chain to a place like vietnam well
i'm just going to make all my stuff over
there because i can pay those workers
way less however generally as part of
negotiating these free trade agreements
you usually demand
some sorry some labor standards on the
uh
side of other countries in order to
bring them onto a more level playing
field so that you're not exporting um
all of those jobs so two really good
examples of this is one
is it the um i can't remember the united
states mexico um
usmca yeah usmca the united states
mexico candidate
free trade agreement yeah um so part of
this agreement that trump champions all
the time was um
i think they demanded like uh an
increase in wages for mexican workers
that worked in certain factories
to to try to dissuade people from
exporting too many jobs over there
um and then another good example is part
of the negotiations for the
trans-pacific partnership
uh obviously dead now but part of those
were historic labor reforms in vietnam
that would have bolstered a lot of the
labor rights in that country and a lot
of those just completely went away
as a result of the tpp negotiations
falling through it's good good for
vietnam that's not good for american
workers
um well if you force them to pay their
workers more it is good for american
workers because
the increased liberalization of trade
means we have another trading partner
that we can buy and sell stuff from but
the fact you have to pay their workers
more means we're not just shipping all
of those jobs overseas because they
still have some minimum level of wages
that they have to pay to discourage that
there there may be those negotiations on
labor rights but the the cost is still
remarkably cheaper to have our factories
all throughout southeast asia than here
in the united states and we've we've
seen that
we've seen the fact that we don't
produce our own medicine anymore sure i
mean it
this this is one of those like insanely
multifaceted things that i
agree with you in practice it becomes a
lot easier to spread
supply chains throughout the world
because it's cheaper in certain areas to
manufacture it that's not always a bad
thing
but it's also a thing that we could
combat if we would have more honest
conversations about
like what is a multilateral trade game
we're supposed to accomplish so for
instance the paris climate accords
so very common criticism that nobody on
the left talks about um is that
these things seem to give a lot of
leeway to developing nations like why
would i join any type of
pollution you know restriction thing
that's going to let china and india
compete uninhibited with now my shackled
economy they can't pollute
like this is insane um so like but but
the only way
that we can address those types of
concerns have to come through
multilateral trade agreements that's it
there's no other way to do it china is
way too big as a country
a few tariffs or a couple sanctions
aren't going to do anything to them they
have access to the rest of the world
market um you have to get together with
a bunch of countries to set these
standards it didn't it didn't work
we thought that these are the the trade
with china
was going to normalize china and make
them freer and better and they went the
other direction
well so there this has been something
i've heard about this since the 90s
this has always been like the china
conspiracy people are always saying i
say people are always saying that like
when china when the middle class booms
when they increase their trade like
they're going to become more liberal the
people are going to demand political
freedoms
doesn't seem to have happened but i
don't think we necessarily need those
things to happen i think we can
acknowledge that china exists as this
kind of like
you know authoritarian behemoth that is
going to do what it's going to do but
the only way that we can accurately deal
with that
is to partner with other countries in
order to enforce like the kinds of
restrictions that we want on them we
can't do it on our own like we've seen
trump try to do it with terrorists
doesn't really work that well
he keeps saying over and over again we
brought them to the table but like not
really
the big things that we were pushing for
related to like intellectual property
rights i think we didn't see any
progress there whatsoever china
continues its
belt road initiative all throughout
europe and asia and everything like it's
either either there i think there's two
outcomes in this
this this china issue full-scale warfare
or capitulation okay how i'm gonna
suggest kindly a third option what if
instead of every single time something
bad happens in the world and we all hide
from each other and get scared and
locked down
what if we continue to reach out be the
world leader that we used to be
in the whole nato world and everything
where we tell other countries like hey
let's all work together on this common
idea and then we pressure china that way
couldn't that be like a better way to do
things
but hasn't that been exactly what
they've been trying to do that's not
been working
well i mean there have been a few key
events especially recently that have
kind of pushed people into
a a lot more kind of a scary area where
they're worried about working deals so
the 2013 syrian refugee crisis for
instance
cost a whole wave of governments in
europe to
have thanks obama well to some extent
yeah
um although bush got us largely involved
with the middle eastern syria was obama
yeah all of it oh it's
complicated uh well i'm sorry you're
right it was the cia
no that's too communist um no no i mean
like the existence of like
the existence of like isis that exists
in syria and gains power in syria like
like a lot of that came from the
destabilization that started in iraq and
a lot of that came from you know
bush that got us into iraq i'm not
saying that obama has absolved this i
think that obama could have done a
better job foreign policy ways but it's
hard it's very difficult and nobody has
gotten that right
uh do you know do you know about the
turkey pipeline um i
believe i've heard of this but tell us
about it the reason why the u.s got
involved in syria well
because the idea was to get syria locked
down so that they could run that
pipeline from from
yeah all throughout their suits i've
seriously heard this from people
yeah but it's it's true 2009 um i think
it was
actually no maybe it was yeah 2009 the
guardian reported this that in 2009
u.s intelligence said we will have a
ground incursion in syria because they
have refused to give us access to build
the pipeline
saying that they would not go against
their ally russia
what russia and syria weren't planning
on doing was using iran to tap the same
well
and run that pipeline into europe
strengthening the russian gas monopoly
in europe
so the u.s had had planned for years
before we actually ended up on the
ground
and then funneling weapons to rebel
groups
eventually built they eventually came
together and we got isis
that that is a story that one could tell
but i don't think that everything that
happened in syria was just a result of
the united states
wanting to like secure an area for that
pipeline that might have been like
a side objective that maybe could have
come about i know that the united states
probably wanted to see assad gone
and if that was gone it wouldn't
surprise me if we wanted somebody loyal
to america
or american interest in there and if
that did happen let me clarify
the guardian reported that in 2009 the
u.s wanted to be in syria
they needed an opportunity to do it when
the arab spring happened the united
states said now's our chance
provided weapons and resources to the
rebels eventually put u.s soldiers on
the ground
now we're involved in that and the same
look uh that's why you know getting into
the biden discussion about war and
conflict
bringing up the syrian refugee crisis
was a product of
yes bush totally and obama
ramp things up um in regards to the
syrian stuff
yeah for sure um in regards to
another reason why foreign policy is
complicated is like a lot of people are
critical about obama and the um
and all of the drone strikes of the
killings was it uh an american citizen i
think we killed any yam men
uh we killed jesus i think i think obama
killed four american citizens yeah
i know there was one that was like super
ultra heated 16 16 year old
in yemen yes yes obama signed off on
blowing up a civilian restaurant in a
country we aren't at war with
and when they when they asked him why
did you kill why do you sign off on
killing the 16 year old
they said we were trying to target
somebody else a terrorist leader
oops when people followed up saying why
did you
authorize a drone strike on a civilian
restaurant in a country worked at war
with
it's just womp sure all those same drone
strikes and all those same bombings have
only increased under trump though
not in the past few years but yes
absolutely in the past few years no they
ran
they've actually been going down quite a
bit they might have gone down where they
started the administration but in the
four years we've had trump in his first
four years he has done more drone
strikes and more foreign bombing than
either obama or correct and hiring
bolton was the stupidest thing the man
because don't have troops in
afghanistan we still have troops in any
room but he's trying to take him out of
syria what do you mean he's trying to
he's been trying to get rid of him for a
long time because did you know that
there was a white house there was a
federal official who lied about the
amount of troops we had in syria to
trick trump into keeping them there
and that when trump said he was ordering
the troops to withdraw from afghanistan
both democrats and republicans got
together and blocked him in congress
trump fired the pentagon civilian
leadership and this was reported by the
ap
in an effort to get loyalists who would
finally pull our troops out of these
countries
this is one of those things where i wish
i knew more information about it i
am i completely do not agree that that
is even remotely possible
you are telling me that the president of
the united states that was able to get
the supreme court to say well i can
tariff china for national security
reasons couldn't control where we were
deploying or withdrawing troops from
um that sounds unbelievable especially
unilaterally approving strikes on like
sulimani and like iraqi airports and
stuff
i know it's messed up stuff i find it
very hard to believe it wasn't
surprising if trump was using this as an
excuse
but i mean even if this was true like
you've got a guy that says he's a
business leader that's supposed to be on
top of handling all this stuff who like
one guy lies to him and now he has no
control over his military he's the
commander-in-chief it's literally the
primary job of the president
they're they're they're there are a lot
of people in government who are doing
everything their power to obstruct trump
appointees yeah i know that's it's one
of these trumps hired a bunch of dumb
people so like come on man but you have
to effectively hire bolton but you have
to ask yourself
at one point is it no longer the deep
state's fault when the deep state is 50
trump appointees maybe trump is just
highly incompetent thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you